el expresidente Alejandro Toledo va a
ser recluido en la cárcel de barbadío
conocida también como la cárcel
presidencial porque ahí se encuentran
los expresidentes Alberto fujimori Pedro
Castillo en esta prisión de barbadío
Toledo va a cumplir 18 meses de prisión
preventiva ordenado por la justicia de
este país hay que señalar que lo que se
le viene a Alejandro Toledo es un
proceso por los presuntos delitos de
lavado de activos y colusión agravada en
el que la fiscalía lo está acusando de
haber recibido sobornos de 35 millones
de dólares el otorgados por la empresa
brasileña odebrecht a cambio de la
construcción de la carretera
interoceánica por estos hechos la
fiscalía está solicitando veinte años de
cárcel contra Toledo pero este no es el
único caso que la justicia peruana tiene
previsto seguir contra el ex mandatario
porque también va a iniciar un juicio
por lavado de activos El caso es
conocido como eco tva en el que las
autoridades peruanas señalan que Toledo
ha usado dinero producto de las
de las coimas que ha recibido para
comprar diverso tipo de inmuebles en
este hecho están comprometidos también
la esposa y la suegra Alejandro Toledo
por los delitos que habría cometido el
ex gobernante la fiscalía está pidiendo
dieciséis años de prisión además de esto
hay que señalar que existen otros
sucesos que ocurrieron durante el
gobierno de Toledo que fue del año 2001
a 2006 en Perú por esa situación es el
gobierno peruano tiene previsto es
solicitar al gobierno de Estados Unidos
una ampliación de la extradición para
poder someter a Toledo por otros delitos
que también habría cometido
bueno Francisco y dentro de todo este
proceso Cuál será la estrategia de la
defensa del ex mandatario
Por lo pronto el expresidente de
Alejandro Toledo antes de venir a Perú
había anunciado que padece cáncer y
requiere medicinas y un cuidado que muy
meticuloso en ese sentido Esa es la
figura que va a usar la defensa de
Alejandro Toledo su abogado en este país
Roberto ciu va a pedir el cambio de
régimen de reclusión Alejandro Toledo
hay que señalar que antes de salir de
Estados Unidos le había pedido a la
justicia peruana que le otorguen la
misma condición que se le está brindando
al expresidente Pablo kuczynski es decir
que le den arresto domiciliario pero la
fiscalía ha dicho que no va a permitir
eso y va a poner todo el recurso de
nulidad ante cualquier emprendimiento de
la defensa de Toledo para cambiar este
régimen también debemos señalar que la
procuraduría está pidiendo que tanto
Toledo como lo demás inculpados que son
30 personas en los hechos de corrupción
entre empresarios ex funcionarios
públicos e intermediarios tenga que
pagar una reparación civil de más de 800
millones de dólares bueno va a haber de
hecho de Toledo para rato y vamos a ver
cómo suceden estas situaciones